[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans cette édition de présidentielle 360
voici les titres
le ministre de l'intérieur va-t-il
devoir démissionner bruno le roux a
employé ses deux filles comme
collaboratrice ponctuelle à l'assemblée
il a rencontré françois hollande et
bernard cazenave en début d'après midi
et doit prendre la parole dans un
instant à bobigny nous sommons
évidemment sur place mort de celui qui
se voyait en gardiens de la gauche henri
emmanuelli est décédé à l'âge de 71 ans
député socialiste président de
l'assemblée nationale premier secrétaire
du ps
hommage unanime de la classe politique
pour celui qui était aussi un des
mentors de benoît hamon
il aura permis aux cinq candidats de
développer leurs projets le premier
débat de la présidentielle d'hier a
aussi séduit les français
près de 10 millions de téléspectateurs
l'ont suivi analyse dans ce journal
et vous pouvez réagir à nos débats sur
twitter avec le hashtag présidentielle
on attend donc la prise de parole de
bruno le roux à bobigny d'un instant à
l'autre pour en parler j'accueille tout
de suite sur le plateau notre
chroniqueur politique
michael à metz et bernard bruno cautrès
pardon chercheur au cnrs et membre du
cevipof le centre de recherches
politiques de sciences po bonjour alors
mickaël bruno le roux doit s'exprimer
dans quelques instants il a rencontré
cet après-midi françois hollande et
bernard cazeneuve et presque rien affûté
sur cette rencontre ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que bruno le roux se
trouve actuellement dans sa
circonscription celle qui l'a vu grandir
en tant que député en seine saint denis
ce qui lui est reproché on le sait
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé dans les
titres alors il a rencontré bernard
cazeneuve il a rencontré besoin de la
république est ce à dire qu'il a donné
sa démission que sa démission est
acceptée ou est ce qu'on l'a fait
démissionner ou est-ce qu'il ne
démissionnera pas on va attendre
quelques minutes pour le savoir ce que
l'on comprend aujourd'hui c'est qu' un
contexte un contexte de crise un
contexte morale éthique depuis la sphère
fillon bien avant depuis la sphère qui a
usé que ça remonte à très loin mais
aujourd'hui ça ne peut plus passer dans
l'opinion publique ça c'est certain
donc on va attendre la décision du
gouvernement quelle qu'elle soit
aujourd'hui ce qui est évident c'est que
ça va servir d'exemple
hier soir dans le débat françois fillon
a parlé de justice tgv à son encontre
on voit qu'aujourd'hui cette justice tgv
pour reprendre son expression et
s'applique à dos effectivement le
parquet national financier s'est déjà
saisie de ces révélations effectuées par
le l'émission quotidien de tmc la
justice au coeur de cette campagne
encore une fois chaque jour on a presque
une nouvelle surprise effet le problème
de cette élection c'est qu'on parle pas
du fond
malheureusement pour nous on essaye d'en
parler dans nos débats aujourd'hui on
voit qu'on est rattrapé par l'énième
feuilleton alors aujourd'hui c'est
solide bruno le roux il ya c'était celui
de françois fillon et demain on verra
encore si c'est encore un autre et c'est
bien dommage ça regrettait ça c'est
certain pour la qualité du débat même si
hier dans le débat quand même évoquer le
fond espérons espérons qu'on puisse
l'invoquer l'évoqué encore donc après
les révélations de l'emploi de la femme
et des enfants de françois fillon c'est
donc bruno le roux un qui est dans la
tourmente pour des accusations
similaires mais que lui est il
véritablement reprochés le rappel des
faits par yona thanh van der vaart bruno
le roux au coeur d'une nouvelle
polémique entre 2009 et 2016 alors qu'il
était député de la seine-saint-denis il
aurait employé ses deux filles comme
collaboratrice parlementaire quand elles
avaient entre 15 et 16 ans leur salaire
total 55 mille euros elle était alors
lycéennes puis étudiante 24 contrats en
tout des cdd qui se sont prolongées
pendant les périodes des vacances
scolaires des deux filles ou en
parallèle à leurs cours et leurs stages
bruno lourds ou répond et veut éviter
tout amalgame avec le pénélope gates
bien entendu j'ai mes filles qui ont
travaillé avec moi sur des été notamment
où des périodes de vacances scolaires
mais jamais en permanence l'information
révélée hier par l'émission quotidien
déstabilise l'actuel ministre de
l'intérieur à plusieurs reprises pendant
ces mêmes contrats les filles étaient en
stage à temps plein ou totalement
absente de l'assemblée nationale ou de
la circonscription de leur père
la position de bruno le roux est très
fragilisée d'autant plus que ces emplois
n'ont jamais été déclaré auprès de la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
on revient avec mes invités mickaël
szames s cette situation évidemment
c'est la sphère fillon qui place le
gouvernement dans cette situation si
jamais bruno le roux est amené à
démissionner c'est françois fillon qui
sera montré lui continue sa campagne
absolue gros celui qui aura tenu un face
à face à la vindicte populaire on
peut-on dire au tuc à face à la pression
aussi de ses amis ou ses ennemis ça
c'est chacun voit sa midi à sa porte lui
l'aura tenue mise en examen certes mais
il aura tenu de rester candidat on va
voir s'il y aura une jurisprudence
françois fillon pour bruno le roux c'est
difficile quand on est ministre de la
république aujourd'hui quand on a parlé
d' exemplarité
quand on a dit et récemment encore à
propos de la faire fi ou et là je fais
ci suscite simplement bruno le roux il
devrait y avoir une règle 5 l'emploi
d'un conjoint par un parlementaire ne
devrait pas être autorisé ça peut prêter
à suspicion ça quand on a déclaré ça il
ya quelques jours à quelques semaines
aujourd'hui se retrouver dans l'oeil du
cyclone ça devient un petit peu
compliqué bruno cautrès bruno le roux le
ministre de l'intérieur
il est aussi chargé d'organiser cette
élection présidentielle est-ce que c'est
nabeul dans sa situation d'organiser
sereinement les élections ça semble très
difficile
il est atteint sur un problème est bien
qui touche plusieurs hommes politiques
dans cette campagne électorale est
décidément cette campagne électorale
donne le sentiment est bien que quelque
chose d'important est en train de se
passer dans la vie politique que le
thème du renouvellement de la vie
politique
le thème de la moralisation de la vie
politique vraiment s'imposer sera sans
aucun doute un des marqueurs de cette
élection et bien sûr bruno le roux
ministre l'intérieur c'est le ministère
de l'intérieur en france qui est en
charge de l'organisation des élections
sa position semble extrêmement difficile
où il faut se rappeler que les français
lorsqu'ils regardent tout ceci est bien
ils ont un regard que nous on connaît
bien dans les enquêtes qu'on réalise au
cevipof à sciences po et bien ils voient
tout ceci avec d'une certaine manière un
certain sentiment de dégoût lorsqu'on
demande aujourd'hui aux français qu
elles aient le sentiment qu'ils
éprouvent lorsqu'il pense à la politique
ben c'est d'abord et avant tout et bien
cette question de la méfiance et du
dégoût et ça ça va pas contribuer bien
sûr à rehausser l'image de la politique
mickels à metz oui c'est le fait pour
c'est un peu ce qu'a dit jean luc
mélenchon
pendant tout le week-end en tout cas
samedi ça résonnait place de la
république dégagisme dégagé condamne au
coup de balai il a fait répéter en
choeur place de la république
ses côtés des l'image du tous pourris ça
peut être un côté très démagogiques très
populiste mais c'est quelque chose qui
résonne énormément en france aujourd'hui
moi qui était sur place de la république
les gens reprenaient en choeur cette
phrase on ne veut plus entendre parler
de cette caste politique disait-il la
question de la moralisation politique
c'est aussi au coeur du contrat que veut
faire passer
emmanuel macron avec les français c'est
vrai qu'il a été un petit peu poussé
aussi par son ami françois bayrou
cette idée de moralisation politique
c'est pas nouveau il ya ça fait des
années qu'on en parle mais elle n'a
jamais jamais au team aussi présente
cette fois bruno cautrès françois
hollande
il avait promis cette république
exemplaire on n'a eu qu'à usac thévenoud
kader arif et maintenant bruno le roux
c'est le coup de grâce pour le président
de la république
excusez moi je vaux coupe bruno l'euro
prend la parole à bobigny elle vous
prêts il ya mesdames messieurs je vois
et j'entends le débat et les
mis-en-cause que suscite le fait sur les
vacances scolaires et universitaires
d'avoir employé mes deux filles durant
leur scolarité
ces contrats ponctuels et officiels
conforme aux règles juridiques des
services de l'assemblée nationale
correspondait tous bien sûr à des
travaux effectivement réalisé ces
moments de travail en commun était
important pour moi comme il était
formateur pour elle dans mes
responsabilités le temps pour être
ensemble n'est pas si fréquent même si
cela ne concerne en aucun cas la mission
que j'ai aujourd'hui celle de ministre
de l'intérieur
je ne veut à aucun prix que ce débat
fait d' amalgame puisse porter atteinte
au travail du gouvernement la
responsabilité particulière qu'impose la
lutte quotidienne contre le terrorisme
contre la délinquance et pour la
maîtrise des flux migratoires implique
de ne prêter le flanc
à aucune instrumentalisation ici en
seine saint denis
chez moi aujourd'hui comme hier et comme
ces vingt dernières années j'ai mis un
point d'honneur à respecter la faune sur
la fonction de député et les devoirs
qu'elle entraîne j'affirme mon honnêteté
dans les rapports humains comme dans
tous mes actes politiques mais ma
responsabilité est aussi de préserver
totalement l'action gouvernementale
c'est pourquoi j'ai adressé au président
de la république ma démission
celle ci me permet sans autre
considération que ce que je suis en tant
qu'homme et en tant que père de famille
d'affirmer clairement mon honnêteté
mon attachement à la vérité et à une
république dont j'ai toujours essayé de
défendre les valeurs ce que je
continuerai bien entendu à faire je vous
remercie
voilà pour cette courte allocution du
ministre de l'intérieur qui démissionne
donc michael parce que sans surprise
c'était presque une fatalité pour lui
aujourd'hui n'avait pas d'autre choix ça
ne pouvait plus passer dans l'opinion
publique
il a bien essayé d'expliquer les raisons
d'hommes pour mettre de côté avec ses
raisons aujourd'hui d'honnêteté et de
responsabilité de ministre de
l'intérieur
comme il a essayé de montrer aujourd'hui
finalement
presque un peu de sensibilité ses terres
ce côté de du temps qu'il voulait passer
avec ses enfants mais ça ça n'existe
plus ça ne peut plus être admis
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion publique
après ce qu'on a connu ces dernières
semaines j'ai dû peut-être qu'il ya un
an ou deux ce sera encore passer là
c'est terminé
donc aujourd'hui il ya eu un exemple de
la part de bruno le roux et ça c'est
peut-être un exemple très politique
aussi ça veut dire qu'on prend le
contrario de ce qu'avait fait françois
fillon françois fillon lui est resté
droit dans ses bottes
aujourd'hui l'exemplarité qu'a voulu
montrer le gouvernement s'est il y a un
problème on règle ce problème et le
problème a été réglé c'était bon boulot
bruno cautrès ça s'est jamais vu ça une
révélation dont la ministre régalien
ministre de l'intérieur qui démissionne
dans la journée ou qu'ils aient
démissionné on sait qu'on n'a pas encore
les détails de cette démission c'est du
jamais vu
peut-être pas du jamais vu on est déjà
eu des des ministres qui ont été obligés
de quitter le gouvernement
suite à des révélations ou et des
accusations on se rappelle de plusieurs
cas dont il joue gros canons de l'époque
en mai dans la journée dans la joie
ça traduit au fond cette cette
accélération du temps dans la réaction
des opinions publiques dans la réaction
de la classe politique et du décalage
entre les deux qui je crois est
aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez
essentiel récemment et bien analysant
les données de l'enquète que le cevipof
réalise sur la confiance politique et
qu'on publie toutes les années j'avais
publié une analyse dont le titre était
jusqu'ici tout va bien et j'avais
emprunté cette phrase célèbre cette
réplique célèbre du film de mathieu
kassovitz la haine pour indiquer au fond
quel était le la cette accélération le
sentiment que de nombreux français
peuvent avoir que jusqu'ici tout va bien
et qu'à chaque fois qu'on leur explique
qu'un homme politique a quelque chose à
sera prêt à se reprocher eh bien il va
expliquer que finalement il est
parfaitement de bonne foi qu'il a pensé
à agir avec toute toute intégrité et
puis que progressivement peut-être
s'approche le sol et le sol c'est
peut-être un accident démocratique un
jour qui est que et bien beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui considèrent que la
démocratie française elle dysfonctionne
elle ne marche pas elle délivre pas les
l'attachement aux principes de
démocratie représentative en france est
toujours très élevé bien sûr mais en
même temps nous voyons nous dans toutes
nos enquêtes l'élévation d'une
niveau d'insatisfaction le sentiment que
les hommes politiques ne sont pas à
l'écouté des problèmes et en plus qui ne
sont pas exemplaires
or les françaises qui vivent dans leur
vie professionnelle c'est que eux s'ils
ne sont pas exemplaires dans leur vie
professionnelle peut être qu'on ne va
pas leur pardonner
donc elle a quelque chose effectivement
qui vient de se passer qui est important
le ministre assume sa responsabilité
et ça c'est plutôt un signe encourageant
oui faut pas oublier qu'on a quelques
jours du premier tour des élections
présidentielles est bonne le roux l'a
rappelé il ne veut prêter aucun plan
l'instrumentalisation
non c'était au santé poindre évidemment
l'instrumentalisation où elle a pris en
tout cas de cette affaire de la part du
front national de la part d'autres
partis politiques peut-être que aussi la
droite même si elle se taisait un petit
peu ce matin au se serait servi un petit
peu de tout cela pour faire campagne
aussi une contre campagne contre
françois fillon pour marquer un peu une
opposition à la sphère françois fillon
voilà il fallait absolument débrancher
cette affaire aujourd'hui le plus vite
possible ça a été fait ça a été très
vite fait vous l'avez rappelé je ne le
vois servi d'exemple on va revenir sur
l'impact sur la campagne est ce que ça
peut fragiliser certains candidats on
pense à benoît hamon il ne fait partie
de wii mais a priori ça ne fragilisera
pas benoît hamon qui avait même a dit
qu'il souhaitait aujourd'hui qui ça
serait mieux que pour nous le roux de
lui-même parts de ses fonctions y'a pas
de raison que ça puisse fragiliser
aujourd'hui benoît hamon qui lui aussi
dans son dans sa campagne fait un
programme sur la moralisation de la vie
politique où il a fait et affiche est
lui aussi tout un listing de programmes
qui voudraient faire
en fait tout va jouer finalement sur la
prochaine mandature acquis aujourd'hui
fera le plus de propositions sur la
transparence sur la moralisation de
cette vie politique n'a vraiment besoin
aujourd'hui ça on le sent fortement et
tout se fera que après cette élection
présidentielle et après les élections
législatives parce qu'on va le rappeler
que le goût le gouvernement aujourd'hui
agi mais le parlement pour l'instant lui
est un peu plus en retrait on attendra
évidemment une nouvelle majorité pour
pouvoir changer cette vie politique
bruno cautrès on assistera pas une
campagne normale cette année ah non
vraiment pas on peut dire c'est vraiment
on a plus de qualificatif pour qualifier
cette élection les uns des autres on
parle des fois de l'élection folle de
l'élection invraisemblable donc on voit
une sorte d' actualité qui est sans fin
on a le sentiment les uns et les autres
que tous les jours quelque chose de nous
nous attend et va se passer ça traduit
quand même quelque chose de très
intéressant non seulement ça traduit qu'
un certain nombre de points de repère de
la vie politique qui sont en train de
trembler sur leurs fondations en
particulier et bien le la vie politique
française bien organisée autour du du de
l'alternance entre la gauche et la
droite et on voit que la bien les deux
plus grandes formations politiques du
pays sont en peine de qualifier leur
candidat pour le deuxième tour on voit
également que tout un tas d'autres
éléments apparaissent de nouvelles
personnalités sont apparus on a parlé d'
emmanuel macron tout à l'heure on a vu
aussi des primaires qui ont donné des
fruits qu'ils étaient des fruits
intéressant avec beaucoup d'intérêt des
français pour ces primaires comme hier
soir beaucoup d'intérêt pour le débat et
en même temps une forme de distance
vis-à-vis de ce jeu qui apparaît aux
français comme un jeu qui est de plus en
plus difficile à décoder comme si au
fond il y avait ce jeu d'élections
présidentielles mais le doute persiste
est ce qu'au fond les grands problèmes
vont être réglés est ce qu'au fond
demain j'aurai davantage de pouvoir
d'achat est ce que mes enfants ne vont
pas connaître le chômage
comment se fait-il que des problèmes
pratiques de la vie tous les jours ne
sont pas réélus le problème vous ne
crois pas c'est que dès demain matin ou
encore parler que de cela voilà nous
mêmes nous le faisons aujourd'hui mais
on va encore avoir un foulard qui va
durer quelques jours sur cet aspect là
je serais pas un peu de nuance était à
la fois je suis comme tout le monde je
souhaiterais que la campagne parle de
l'opposition entre des visions de la
société française une confrontation
entre des programmes et en même temps
parler de ces affaires là c'est quand
même aussi parlé de problèmes
fondamentaux
ça n'est pas uniquement anecdotique on
va revenir parce qu'ils se savaient un
de l'oeil du cyclone depuis les
révélations de l'émission côté d'hier
soir le ministre de l'intérieur bruno le
roux a donc démissionné mais il a tout
de même tenu à honorer ce matin son
audition au sénat avant de finalement
annulé tous ses autres rendez vous prévu
récit de sa journée mouvementée par
fabien rey caire il vient de l'annoncer
face au soupçon d'emplois fictifs bruno
le roux a été forcé de démissionner
retour sur une journée mouvementée
il est 9 heures 25 alors qu'il est
entendu par la commission des lois du
sénat le ministre de l'intérieur est
interrompu en pleine audition
suivez-moi
je suspends la séance il doit quitter la
salle l'audition va reprendre tandis que
les journalistes sont prévenus d'une
déclaration à la presse imminente
les surprises le ministre de l'intérieur
va finalement s'éclipser en évitant les
caméras dans la foulée tous ses
déplacements de la journée sont annulés
en fin de matinée bernard cazeneuve
sans évoquer directement la sphère fait
une déclaration visiblement agacé
lorsqu'on est attaché à l'autorité de
l'état on est impeccable face aux
institutions et aux règles qui les
régissent sans quoi l'autorité de l'état
est abaissé à la réunion du groupe ps du
sénat
la gêne est palpable si vous avez des
enfants qui font des études de droit et
cetera pouvez comprendre que vous
puissiez éventuellement les faire
travailler
alors là franchement c'est vraiment ils
tendront je trouve cette histoire utile
en ce moment chez les républicains
l'ironie est de mise ça va être
intéressant de voir un peu ce sera très
instructif de voir le comportement du
parquet national financier le parquet
national financier ne sera pas long à
réagir en ouvrant une enquête
préliminaire dans l'après midi à 14h30
bruno le roux est reçu par françois
hollande
en présence de bernard cazeneuve ce soir
il n'est plus ministre de l'intérieur
nickel maintenant il va falloir trouver
un nouveau misé à l'intérieur oui et
peut-être aussi l'idée qui est que
bernard cazeneuve qui a exercé cette
fonction est pour nous la rappeler nous
sommes dans un contexte extrêmement
dangereux évidemment de risques
d'attentats de l'état d'urgence pourrait
très bien reprendre ce poste à son
compte tout évidemment restant premier
ministre
c'est déjà arrivé dans le passé fort
lointain mais ça peut exister
aujourd'hui
ou alors nommé un nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur c'est vrai qu'il ya des noms
qui ont circulé et qui circule depuis
longtemps même si celui ci avait refusé
un peu tant d'autres ministères ou même
celui ci s'était finalement celui de
françois rebsamen un proche de françois
hollande qui aujourd'hui reste maire de
dijon est également président de la
fédération des villes je vous interromps
passé puisque matthias fekl vient d'être
nommé ministre de l'intérieur en
remplacement de bruno le roux un jeune
pousse notamment de la hollande y qui
aujourd'hui était ministre du commerce
extérieur qui avait fait ses faits
d'armes il ya peu de temps au tour
du ceta vous savez ces contrats contrat
signé ce traité content de signer avec
les états unis où avec le canada doc
matthias fekl ça fait quelques temps
déjà qu'il se fait voir de la part
évidemment dans ce gouvernement qu'il
évolue où il a fait un petit peu de peu
les coudes on va dire ça comme ça c'est
la jeune c'est la jeune pousse qui
grandit aujourd'hui rien génération et
un dernier mot également pas trop
exposer pour organiser ainsi ces
élections-là pas vu être attaqué par
l'opposition
par contre il a monté un club de
réflexion en interne on sent aussi qu'il
a fait des propositions sur la
transparence sur la vie démocratique
avec aussi ses clubs de natation ces
think tank comme on les appelle
aujourd'hui
matthias fekl ils travaillent dans
l'ombre depuis un petit moment ils ne
seraient pas beaucoup entendre parler de
lui mais c'est vrai qu' évidemment
aujourd'hui il prend du galon à ce poste
et puis est ce que ça va donner me rase
put non plus très longtemps c'est
surtout l'organisation de cette élection
présidentielle qui va être motivé avant
la charge
merci beaucoup michael pour cet
éclairage on va revenir au reste de
l'actualité fait ce qui hier il y eut
trois heures et demie de débats qui ont
permis à cinq candidats de présenter
leurs projets la première confrontation
télévisée de cette campagne a aussi
attiré les français avec près de 10
millions de téléspectateurs qui l'ont
suivi et parmi eux notre journaliste
quand un calme et qui revient pour nous
sur les moments clés de cette émission
la première escarmouche entre les
candidats intervient après une heure de
débats sans éclat les compétiteurs
débattent alors de laïcité
quand marine le pen prend emmanuel
macron à parti voulait pas voir la
réalité de la gravité de ce qui se passe
je suis bel et bien justement fait
quelques années y avait pas de burkini
sur les plages je sais que vous êtes
pour monsieur macron mais on n'avait pas
vu l'échec
madame le pen vous serez gentil je ne
sais ce que vous avez des gravats et non
je ne vous fais pas parlé je n'ai pas
besoin d'un ventriloque
je vous assure tout va très bien quand
j'ai quelque chose à dire je le dis
clairement c'est mon habitude alors que
pensez-vous du burkini monsieur je les
dis très clairement ça n'a rien à voir
avec la laïcité parce que ça n'est pas
cultuelle c'est un sujet d'ordre public
emmanuel macron qui est à plusieurs
reprises au centre des attaques lors des
trois heures vingt de débat comme lors
de cet échange entre les deux anciens
ministres de françois hollande il faut
tenir les engagements et ne pas être
tenant lié bien sûr financer votre
campagne vais vous dire je vais être
totalement mais là quand je prends
l'engagement de notre tenue par personne
faut bien qu'il ya débat au ps
oui les rires du public résultat
plusieurs reprises lors de l'émission
jean luc mélenchon réussit même à faire
sourire l'audience sur un sujet aussi
sensible que les affaires puis admirer
veaux pudeur de gazelle quand vous dites
que la campagne a été pollué je parle
pas pour vous madame a été polluée par
les affaires de certains d'entre vous
pardon pas moi non mais je tiens à le
préciser ici avec deux personnes qui
sont concernées monsieur fillon et
madame le pen ça pourrait venir les
trois autres nous n'avons rien à voir
avec tout ça alors s'il vous plaît ne
mettez pas dans le même sac
françois fillon se montre est faste et
en première partie du débat jusqu'au
questions économiques où il est plus à
l'aise le vrai serial killer du pouvoir
d'achat des français c'est madame le pen
avec la sortie de l'euro et le
rétablissement du franc avec une
inflation galopante
toutes les mesures que vous venez de
proposer n'auront plus aucune efficacité
en termes d'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat une émission qui a pu sembler
longue et balayant trop de sujets dans
le même temps mais où le débat sur des
sujets essentiels a bien eu lieu entre
les candidats et pour analyser ce
premier un grand rendez vous de la
campagne présidentielle je suis toujours
avec bruno cautrès chercheur au cnrs et
membre du cevipof
or déjà premiers enseignements ce débat
il a finalement attiré 10 millions de
français
à l'heure des affaires et du
désenchantement pour la politique
finalement ça attire encore ces débats
bien sûr retrouve là quelque chose qu'on
connaît bien une sorte de paradoxe du
franc des français dans leur rapport à
aux élections et à la démocratie
à la fois très critique sur la classe
politique même au delà de très critique
carrément vraiment extrêmement défiants
vis-à-vis de la classe politique et dans
le même temps dans l'attentes vis-à-vis
de cette classe politique et dans
l'intérêt vis-à-vis de la politique on
constate dans les enquêtes qu'on réalise
qu'on a à la fois un intérêt soutenu
pour la campagne de la présidentielle et
en même temps que peut-être on a pour le
moment un niveau de participation qui ne
serait peut-être pas aussi haut que la
participation dans les élections
présidentielles précédentes je suis
prudent sur cette question et je suis
prudent pour cette question parce qu'il
ya deux éléments de cette campagne
présidentielle qui normalement intéresse
beaucoup les électeurs
le résultat semble incertain en tout cas
le résultat du premier tour semble
encore aujourd'hui incertain malgré le
fait que les enquêtes d'opinion donnent
très clairement deux des candidats pour
le moment qualifié et dans le même temps
on a une sorte de casting de rêve d'une
certaine manière dans cette élection
présidentielle parce qu'on a cinq
personnalités
les principaux candidats qu'on a vu hier
des personnalités très différentes très
opposées au plan idéologique
on a vu hier soir dans le débat et bien
des grandes oppositions des grands
clivages politiques et idéologiques se
s'exprimer sur la question de
l'immigration sur la question de la
réduction des inégalités sur la question
du travail
donc normalement ça ça devrait plutôt a
été assez des électeurs merci bruno
cautrès je vous propose maintenant de
réécouter la conférence de presse de
bruno le roux le ministre de l'intérieur
qui a donc annoncé sa démission on les
écoute
bien mesdames messieurs je vois et
j'entends le débat et les mis-en-cause
que suscite le fait sur les vacances
scolaires et universitaires d'avoir
employé mes deux filles durant leur
scolarité
ces contrats ponctuels et officiels
conforme aux règles juridiques des
services de l'assemblée nationale
correspondait tous bien sûr à des
travaux effectivement réalisé ces
moments de travail en commun était
important pour moi comme il était
formateur pour elle dans mes
responsabilités le temps pour être
ensemble n'est pas si fréquent même si
cela ne concerne en aucun cas la mission
que j'ai aujourd'hui celle de ministre
de l'intérieur
je ne veut à aucun prix que ce débat
fait d' amalgame puisse porter atteinte
au travail du gouvernement la
responsabilité particulière qu'impose la
lutte quotidienne contre le terrorisme
contre la délinquance et pour la
maîtrise des flux migratoires implique
de ne prêter le flanc à aucune
instrumentalisation ici en seine saint
denis
chez moi aujourd'hui comme hier et comme
ces vingt dernières années j'ai mis un
point d'honneur à respecter la faune
cieux de la fonction de député et les
devoirs qu'elle entraîne j'affirme mon
honnêteté dans les rapports humains
comme dans tous mes actes politiques
mais ma responsabilité est aussi de
préserver totalement l'action
gouvernementale
c'est pourquoi j'ai adressé au président
de la république ma démission
celle ci me permet sans autre
considération que ce que je suis en tant
qu'homme et en tant que père de famille
d'affirmer clairement mon honnêteté
mon attachement à la vérité et à une
république dont j'ai toujours essayé de
défendre les valeurs ce que je
continuerai bien entendu à faire je vous
remercie
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi tout de suite
c'est l'heure de l'épreuve de vérité
michael à metz reçoit clémentine autain
soutien de jean luc mélenchon excellente
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
je suis